have you guys ever been intimidated by
another actor or a director
where you could actually feel that
intimidation i'm intimidated by jason
daly
still is i'm glad i'm glad he said it
that's why i get his autograph i mean
you've worked with somebody
you've worked with some of the biggest
names i mean both of you i mean you've
been around at your
hollywood royalty i mean you're you know
you it's you got to think there's
somewhere along the line where you're
like you
i mean was it was a few good men with
nicholson was that was great
that was i mean that was the only time
i've ever gone to work
um and actually half our cast
went into work on their day off because
the only two people working that day
were jack nicholson and tom cruise
and i just sneak in the back of the
courtroom set and i just want to see
and then i look around and every other
actor on the show and a couple others i
think bruce willis
uh because he was with me and uh
yeah it was the gallery was just full of
people and he did that in two takes
the big one yeah you can't handle the
truth there's two takes he did the whole
scene
in two takes uh and he had such a great
way of learning it he would record
he would read it and record it on a tape
and then he would just play the tape in
his
car forever until he had to go do the
scene and
and the dialogue he just memorized it
it was it was a part of him and so when
he went to go do that scene
i mean he just blew the room away and
it was the first time i'd ever seen it
and rob reiner just said well
there's nothing else we can do with that
thank you very much and he wrapped
everybody early
uh that whole speech yeah
you need me on that line you want me
that was what two takes the entire
scene jesus which is it's got to be 15
to 20 pages it's the whole crescendo of
the film did it in two takes
but you weren't intimidated by him no
because he made a point
to make sure i mean i i certainly knew
who i was working with
um but he made such a gracious point of
making sure i felt comfortable and
welcome and
and uh jt walsh was on that film
who has since passed uh i was friends
with him he was great friends with
mr nicholson and so so yeah i i've i've
found that the people that i have worked
with that are worthy of being
intimidated
are also really kind and go out of their
way to make sure you feel comfortable so
that you can do your best work with them
wow jason about you i mean you worked
with gene hackman didn't you
i worked with hackman i worked with uh
duvall
i mean that those guys seemed like
hackman seems like he'd be difficult
he's one of my favorites but he seems
like he'd be like you know he had a
limited
uh few days on geronimo and i gotta say
like kiefer said one of the first things
he came up to me and said
that he had seen a movie of mine or two
of them
that he really liked this and that
helped and that helped out
um and but i don't you know i don't
that did help but i i i was excited to
work with people like it's like playing
you want to play with tennis
with people that are good and it was a
similar situation that keeper said when
i did sleepers because hoffman and
deniro were wearing it
and they had never acted together
because you know this is back in 93 or
94 so
of course everyone showed up and it was
in a courtroom so
in the same thing everybody was in the
gallery and
it was funny because levinson was the
director barry levinson and for the
first few takes it was almost like no
one was acting
he sort of had to stop and then call
them over and say
it's okay let's let's act they were all
everyone was underplaying everybody
um but uh i don't know i mean no
i liked it look if the person in front
of you the more
real they are the more inventive they
are
that gives you better choices it's
better to play off that it's better to
reflect off that i've always felt that
what do you what if you have an actor
that you look up to that's just
brilliant that is just like you're going
this is [ __ ] terrible
this person's just [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
bed in front of me and that's
exactly what i felt when i did that that
guest star on smallville
you're because lex luthor had always
been my hero
yeah yeah so i mean that's had to happen
where you're one of your icons and the
guys like and no one's given direction
like this is not going to be good i i
in all fairness i i'm i'm i'm not trying
to be politically correct i have not had
that experience
um you know i i think for me over the
course of my career
sometimes maybe i've misjudged the
quality of the material
i think we all have you know i think and
that's no one's fault but mine right um
but the actors that i've worked with uh
you know not only have i been really
lucky and fortunate to work with some
incredible actors that
everybody knows and that are huge icons
and and they were not disappointing they
were
phenomenal what they did i've worked
with day players
that'll blow your hair back i mean that
are really
great um you know uh
that's as exciting as anything it is
exciting because you're also never going
to see those day players again yeah
and you you get in there with a day
player
and you know every day you go to work
it's i'm going to dance
and to have a good dancing partner wow
you know
you